what can you teach us about raising the
stakes mm um I think the biggest thing
to think about when raising the stakes
is how is it then going to affect the
rest of the story so sometimes the
stakes will be raised just because the
stakes need to be raised right so there
just be this extra thing that's just
thrown in there so people can go oh
right but again if it's not attached to
anything if it's not gonna make our
character have to make a real decision
that's going to affect them and then
affect the rest of the story sometimes
when those stakes are raised that's when
that redirection happens in the film
where we thought that this was the goal
they were going after after but then the
stakes get raised and now they are going
in a different direction so again
everything is causing effect so even the
thing that causes the stakes to raise
has to be obvious for your audience to
understand what's happening right and
then the fact that the stakes are being
raised like for example let's just make
something simple let's say it's a
singing contest and the the prize is
$1,000 and I'm a person who is trying to
go to college and I really need this
$1,000 because it's gonna pay for my
dorm right so the stakes are if I don't
get the thousand dollars I don't have a
dorm right you can raise the stakes by
saying my mother is also sick at home
and I just went to the doctor's office
and they said they can't start her her
treatment unless I can give a deposit of
$1,000 so sure you cared when she wasn't
gonna have a dorm room but she knows she
already has a house and she lives with
her mother so she doesn't have a dorm
room right but now - no but her mother
needs treatment and that extra thing
that she might find out along the way
now the dorm room doesn't matter at all
the stakes are raised we want her to win
this singing competition if there were
no dorm room and there were no mother we
still might want her to win the singing
competition but if she didn't okay I
mean maybe was a nice movie you know
like yay she sang a song and she got her
$1,000 whoo we all at home know $1,000
not a lot of money right but
simply by giving they're giving it a
stake in the first place well I really
want to be able to move in the dorm but
my mother can't afford the dorm so if I
get this $1,000 I can move into the dorm
and start my independent life now we're
like okay we could get with that that's
relatable we understand that cool but
then along the way mom gets sick she
goes to the doctor that bill was a
thousand dollars let's say it's 750
let's say it's a thousand let's say it's
1,100 you know it's probably not gonna
be right on the nose you know but every
day's but whatever it is we now know
that if she wins that money she can help
her mom so the stakes have been raised
because it helps us to get that much
more invested so that she went so that
she we root for her the stakes are about
us being able to root for that character
so if that's gonna help us root for the
character more and let's go there but if
it really doesn't change it like let's
say it's a thousand dollars for the dorm
and then suddenly now you could win
eleven hundred dollars it's like who
cares if there's another 100 dollars
that you can get like how does that
really raised the stakes or change the
story like sure it changes the money and
if we think the money are the stakes
then now we're thinking I've made a
difference it's now $1100 I really got
to get it now no not very much but just
by figuring out something that's going
to affect that character and and using
that to raise the stakes is going to be
that going to make that much more of a
difference
you